(exciting, quick-paced music)
(applause)
So, we've heard a
lot of amazing stories
and information tonight
about the various ways
that we can lose cultural
heritage to looting,
but we haven't really
talked about losing
cultural heritage
to armed conflict
and the kind of looting
that basically just happens
when you have an entire
nation, like Nazi Germany,
kind of devoted to looting
on the most massive
scale in history.
There was a recent movie
called "The Monuments Men"
that kind of, in a
fictionalized way,
devoted itself to talking
about the Monuments Men
and these were really my heroes.
When I was in grad school
studying art history
and also serving as a
young military officer
and I thought wow,
that's pretty cool.
I would love to save art as
part of my military career.
There were fewer than 350
Monuments Men all together.
Most of them were
in the US military,
a small handful of them were
from the British military
and then the other
Allied forces.
Think of this in a conflict
of over a billion people
throughout World War II.
While we have this amazing
story, the Monuments Men,
not a lot of people remembered
it and I think the movie
really brought to bear
this awareness about
cultural property
during armed conflict
and the risk that it takes.
Yes, of course,
people are killed
and people are displaced
on a massive scale,
but what happens to
their identity, to
their cultural heritage
and how did the Nazi looting
of millions of objects
and particularly from
European museums and
Jewish collections where people
were targeted specifically
because of their collections,
like the Rothschild Family,
et cetera, how do
you combat that?
We had this small group of
people dedicated to this.
This is James Rorimer who
was a serving military
and infantry officer
and basically most of
the Monuments Men were already
actively serving in the military
and the cultural heritage
professional community,
the museums community
essentially,
told the military where
to find these folks
within the ranks who had
this kind of capability.
James Rorimer was a curator at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
They brought him out of
the infantry and over
to the Monuments Men
and they worked kind
of all across Europe,
first of all, preventing
or trying to prevent
through mapping,
by providing maps to the
military to keep them
from hitting sites
with bombing, but then
later as they discovered the
looted material that the Nazis
were keeping around in
Austria and Germany,
finding that material,
figuring out a way to
repatriate it to its country
of origin so it could be
returned to its rightful owners.
So we learned a big lesson
from that and the
countries of the world
got together and
decided to create a new
international treaty
at the 1954 Hague
Convention specifically to
protect cultural heritage
during armed conflict,
but that doesn't mean that
it necessarily worked.
You can make treaties, but
a lot of times the countries
involved in conflicts don't
necessarily adhere to them.
We had terrible situations,
like the intentional
targeting of cultural heritage
in the Bosnia Conflict,
we had the deliberate
destruction of Bamiyan Buddhas
by the Taliban and I
think most of us remember
the 2003 looting
of the Iraq Museum.
It was very much in the
media that everything
from the museum was
completely gone.
That actually turned
out not to be true.
The museum staff hid
many of those collections
or most of the collections
in a secret storage location.
The real saviors of
cultural heritage in these
terrible situations of
disaster and armed conflict
and looting are the people
who take care of it every day.
Those curators, those
museum directors who
often risk their lives
to do this and this was the
same case in the Iraq Museum.
But they did indeed lose
more than 15,000 objects
from the collection,
that's an estimate.
Documentation, very
important, you don't know
what's been looted from
your museum if it hasn't
properly been cataloged and
photographed to begin with.
Unfortunately, that was the
case with the Iraq Museum.
Under the ten years of
sanctions they hadn't
really been able to take
the time to document
excavation material
that was coming into the museum.
It kind of got boxed
and put in storage
and that was the first
place the looters went
was to the storage areas.
They couldn't hide everything.
Many, many storage magazines,
over a million objects
were in this museum
when it was looted
and unfortunately, many
of the regional museums
had stored their collections
in Baghdad for safekeeping
which turned out
to be not so safe.
You'd think there was
an international group,
sort of a cultural
heritage rescue squad
that parachutes in after
an incident like this
and that's what I thought.
I was a very naive major
who was assigned to go
to Baghdad to help with
the museum and to help
advise the Minister of
Culture as an art historian
and museum curator myself
and we suddenly realized
that we had a much
larger scale problem than
just the museum looting.
We had looting of archaeological
sites throughout the country.
Under Sadaam Hussein,
death was the penalty
for looting if you got caught,
but suddenly here was a
really unstable situation
with looting happening
in the city of Baghdad
so it wasn't very easy to
go out to the countryside
and protect
archaeological sites.
And so here's the extent
of the Monuments Men
for Baghdad in 2003 and
one of them was a woman.
There were Monuments Women
in World War II as well.
My colleague, Wes Sumner there,
Captain Wes Sumner at the time,
was a landscape archaeologist
so he preceded me in Baghdad
and when I arrived after
the looting, I was called up
as an individual and
went straight to Baghdad
and he said, "Wow. Okay,
good luck with this
because I'm going to go
save the National Zoo now,"
and that's exactly
what he proceeded to do
and he wrote a
wonderful book about it.
But I just want to
point out that we're
at the Central Bank of Iraq
in this photo in Baghdad
and we're here because
a wonderful collection
of archaeological artifacts
from the site at Nimrud,
often referred to has
the Treasure of Nimrud
which is a very
important, probably next
to King Tut's Treasure
and the Bactrian Hoard, probably
the third most important
treasure of the like.
National Geographic
was very, very worried
about the status
of this collection
and had representatives
there on the ground.
They had a project
where they actually paid
to pump water out of
the basement of the
Iraq National Museum
and why the military hadn't
figured out how to do this yet,
I still don't have a clue,
and it had to be done
more than once because they
were having a hard time
finding out where the
water was coming in.
But finally they were able
to do so and ten years later,
I just want to thank
my colleagues at
National Geographic
for contributing to
that and allowing us
to safeguard this really
important cultural resource.
Coming back and realizing
that there really isn't
an organization who
does this kind of
cultural heritage rescue,
like on the ground
immediate response, like
Doctors Without Borders
does for people, I really
realized that there is not
that kind of museum for culture.
We have UNESCO which is a
really important organization
that does major cultural
heritage preservation projects,
but I am talking about real
have a bag packed by your door
and have all your shots and
go and help your colleagues
in a disaster
situation like this.
We created the US Committee
of the Blue Shield.
It's a non-profit
organization that's part of
an international network
to do this or support
this kind of work, but
it's still very difficult
and I'll talk about some
of the ongoing challenges
of trying to do this kind
of work internationally.
I don't think I have to go
too far into the problems
with Egyptian sites, but
I have to say it felt
a little bit, uh,
déjà vu seeing images of...
in a major archaeological
museum in a country
where there was
horrible instability
and seeing images of soldiers
inside the National Museum
in Egypt, a place that I'd
only gotten an opportunity
to visit once.
Worried very much about what was
going to happen with the sites.
Another major area where
we've seen intentional
destruction of cultural heritage
recently, you've heard about
the Jihadist groups who
occupied Northern Mali
and finally in January of
2012, they were driven out
by French forces, but
not before they did
a tremendous amount of damage
to the cultural heritage
of the region and
particularly the historic city
of Timbuktu where they
damaged, they burned
many of the manuscript
collections of the
Ahmed Baba Library.
They looted museums,
as you can see there.
They destroyed the
Sufi Saint's Mausoleums
around the city of
Timbuktu and they also,
in a really insidious
way, prevented Malians
from practicing their very
important, intangible heritage.
No singing, no traditional
dress, women were not
allowed to wear their hair
the way they wanted to,
men were required to
dress in a certain way
and they weren't allowed to
have dance, poetry or theater.
So these things, for Malians,
were almost as damaging
to their culture as seeing
the objects destroyed.
And then finally, the really
terrible scenario that we're
experiencing now with
the Syrian civil war.
This is the ancient
souk in Aleppo.
This is just one example of
the many, many tragic cases.
The city of Aleppo is
a world heritage site
and it has been pretty much
devastated during the conflict.
The Grand Mosque has
been grievously damaged.
The whole central ancient
part of the city damaged.
Krak des Chevaliers,
the Crusader Fortress,
another world heritage
site, very much devastated
from being used as a
military base of operations
and the fighting going
on between the two sides.
Those are just a few examples.
So what can we do about it?
Resources, well where I
work, the Smithsonian
a few years ago recognized
that there is a need
for this type of response
and with our resources
that we have, 19 museums,
9 research centers, a zoo
and more than 6,000 colleagues
that I can call upon
for their time and their
expertise, it's become
really clear that through
partnerships, sort of
whole of government approach,
talking with organizations
within government, like
the Department of State,
USAID, the Department of
Defense, that we can have
a lot of effect and then
partnering with non-governmental
organizations and non-profits
like National Geographic,
the Blue Shield, like
the International
Council of Museums,
et cetera, that we
can have an effect.
In order to help with this darth
of modern day Monuments Men,
as we like to say, the
Blue Shield instituted
a program of training
US military forces
about cultural
property protection,
specifically Civil
Affairs Units.
The World War II Monuments
Men were Civil Affairs
and they still are today.
This is a very recent one,
just a couple of weeks ago.
We had Marines from the Civil
Military Operations School
at Quantico at the
National Portrait Gallery
and American Art Museum
training on packing and crating
in emergency situations.
The Haiti Project was a
big area where Smithsonian
really recognized
the need to jump in
and help with cultural recovery.
During that, we partnered
with a number of organizations
including the American
Institute for Conservation
which is based here
in DC, the President's
Committee on the Arts
and Humanities helped us
get it kicked off with
Michelle Obama's involvement
and we were able to help
our Haitian colleagues
save more than 30,000
objects of their heritage
over an 18 month project.
Here are the Holy Trinity
Murals that were saved
and these are being
restored until they can
build a new church.
We have a museum
professional training program
at the Smithsonian which
works around the world,
but in particular
recently we went to Mali
to help train their
museum professionals,
plus professionals
from eight other west
African countries
on disaster risk
management, thinking about
using museums for
post-conflict reconciliation
and other programs to really
help museum professionals
think about that what-if
scenario, what if this
could happen to my museum
or if it already has,
sharing information about
how you were able to
save your collections.
We hope to be able to serve
as a point of coordination
for multiple partnerships
to help be that
emergency responder
for cultural heritage,
to help our colleagues
who are under duress
from natural disasters
and armed conflicts
to save their collections and
to train about documentation
and international legal
instruments that can
help worldwide in saving
our cultural heritage.
Thanks a lot.
(applause)
(airy, peaceful music)